on utilise la bouillie bordelaise
pourquoi parce qu'il ya du cuivre dedans
et qui en a naturellement dans le sol
et puis qu'il pourra sortir aussi donc
il ya 3500 m² à désherber
ça nous prend beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de temps ludovic est devenu un pro du
maraîchage depuis qu'il a intégré les
jardins du coeur en janvier dernier
éloignées du monde du travail pendant un
an il a trouvé cette réinsertion
professionnelle par pôle emploi
ils travaillent ici 24 heures par
semaine payées au smic mais il a
retrouvé bien plus qu'un salaire world
du rythme et puis une certaine
valorisation s'est pas innocent planter
une graine une graine ça pousse et puis
ensuite on la récolte pour la manger ou
aussi pour la redistribuer aux
bénéficiaires des restos du coeur
c'est pour ça très valorisant de
travailler ici fait du bien au moral
vous avez des piments les poivrons et
basilic pour ces journées portes
ouvertes ce sont des salariés qui joue
les guides
l'occasion pour les visiteurs d'échanger
avec plants de tomates
donc quand la sont 40 à chaque fois ça
nous prend ça nous prend le temps parce
que des fois des graines sont tellement
de films qu'on est obligé d'y aller à la
passe à épiler c'est du travail
d'orfèvre
là vous avez les aubergines avec des
oeillets d'inde très important pour les
buggy
quand on voit le travail qu'ils font on
peut que les féliciter
c'est très important parce que c'est une
ouverture aussi sur sur l'extérieur
c'est nous faire connaître aussi que
reconnaître aussi notre travail c'est
valorisant si pour les salariés qui
travaillent ici toute l'année qui se
donne du mal
et voilà c'est très valorisant pour eux
ces portes ouvertes sont les deux seules
journées de l'année où les légumes sont
vendus à des particuliers
l'an dernier cette vente a permis de
récolter 1500 euros réinvestis dans les
jardins le reste du temps toute la
production et distribués aux
bénéficiaires des restes du coeur du
loir et cher soit plus de 6 tonnes en